[Music]
the very first sin in our very first
video was this movie exists the movie
was the amazing spider-man now every
time we've launched a video since then
we get asked why this movie exists is
not included for that movie as well
allow us to clarify thus in just a bit
the amazing spider-man was released in
May of 2012 exactly five years after Sam
Raimi's let us never speak of it again
spider-man 3 debacle and only ten years
after that trilogies first movie now it
doesn't matter that Sony had to make the
film or they risk losing the rights I
know all that and I don't care as a
movie goer as a consumer and lover of
film I cannot tolerate a reboot of a
character five years after the most
recent version that's just business pure
and simple
I thought creativity it's not fucking
art that's a business decision nothing
kills suspension of disbelief faster
than the studio itself saying look you
know quality was actually pretty far
from our minds on this one this movie
exists doesn't mean this movie is such a
piece of they never should have made it
means it's too damn consumed for a
reboot of spider-man damn it oh and for
the record we both ended up actually
loving that movie
[Music]